michael bloomberg officially enters the
race democrats compete for nuttiest
solution on climate change hand we
checked the mailbag i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
is how my listeners secure that in order
to tell I secure my internet join them
at expressive VPN calm / man ok well
yesterday was a busy day the show we did
the radio show and then went over to
Stanford did a big speech front of 1700
kids the the Stanford left had attempted
to shut this thing down for a while I
mean they they were ripping down posters
and putting up little notes about how I
was I was going to assault minority
communities and I was going to incite
violence against minority communities
and my speech was actually about the
convenient alliance between the radical
left and the alt right there is this
sort of newfangled alright thing that's
happening in which a bunch of people who
are basically white supremacists pretend
that they are actually just kind of
normal Trump supporters even though they
overtly say radically racist or
radically anti-semitic overtly white
supremacist things and then they've been
going to various college events for
people like Dan Crenshaw or charlie Kirk
or Matt Walsh and then they've been
asking idiotic questions to them and
disgusting questions to them in an
attempt to show that they are the true
conservatives I talked about that and
how the fact is that the left what was
that they loved it because their entire
goal is to lump in the entire mainstream
right with the alright so that was the
topic of the speech so it was sort of an
awkward moment for the left I will say
it was an awkward moment because as I am
doing a 35 to 40 minute speech about the
evils of white supremacism and how
racism is evil and how people who hijack
conservative language in order to
promote racism are disgusting as I'm
doing that a bunch of these idiot lefty
students who just I mean beyond having
no manners are just stupid they get up
in the middle of the of the actual
speech and they decide it would be a
good time like well while I'm ripping
Nazis well I'm actually ripping white
supremacists they say now would be an
excellent time to get up and protest
here's a little bit of what it sounded
like
[Applause]
a question that's
it's okay i-i-i-i I have one question
are you protesting the part where I'm
condemning the Nazis like you here I'm
doing right now do you have ears
I'm literally condemning Nazis and
you're telling me to leave do you hear
yourselves
[Applause]
I gotta be honest with you I am I'm
extraordinarily puzzled I'm standing up
here bashing the living out of Nazis and
they're telling me I have to leave over
it what's a guy gotta do the left is so
all-fired interested and a hard left is
so all-fired interested in lumping
everybody on the mainstream right in
with the white supremacist that they
will literally get up and shout for
people to leave while they are ripping
white supremacism and it does show the
agenda of the far left and by the way it
extends over into the media the Boston
Globe last week suggested that the Daily
wire was an alt right outpost we forced
them to retract that follows on the
Economist suggesting that I'm an alt
right sage we forced them to retract it
just as incredible I thought that was
worthy of note and it does demonstrate
the complete disconnect from reality
that is being had by so many people on
the radical left including in the
mainstream Democratic Party
unfortunately okay meanwhile the big
news of the day is that Michael
Bloomberg is jumping into the race
whoo-hoo now he's that really big news
that Michael Bloomberg is jumping into
the race you mean it's illusional
billionaire from New York is jumping
into the race it's not particularly
shocking Bloomberg has been talking
about it for a while he sort of has the
same attitude that Howard Schultz the
former CEO of Starbucks had when he was
talking about jumping into the race
which is there aren't enough moderates
in the Democratic Party to actually win
an election he of course is correct and
that's why Joe Biden is the best shot
for Democrats to win the election of
2020 and not Elizabeth Warren you can
see the Bloomberg is frightened that
Warren is gonna get the nomination he's
been thinking about jumping in for quite
a while does he actually have a base the
answer is pretty much no pretty much no
and Elizabeth Warren is doing exactly
what you would expect her to do she is
suggesting of course that Bloomberg is a
billionaire and therefore he's bad
Elizabeth Warren who is what if they
have the amount of money by the way
she's a very very nice house in
Cambridge Massachusetts Elizabeth Warren
pretending that she is not of the elite
is one of the more amusing factors in
this race it really is but Bloomberg is
crazy if he thinks that he's getting any
level of support in this primary it's
also funny that that Bloomberg is now
considered a moderate I mean seriously
because Bloomberg his policies in New
York with for example banning certain
soda sizes right that it's just been
like he's a full on government control
fanatic and there's somebody who wanted
to ban basically all guns in the city
New York this is somebody who was intent
on taxing the hell out of soda he
actually closed the Manhattan worship
services of something like 57 churches
and synagogues
according to NYC religion that info way
back when this is 2012 in a move with no
precedent in New York City history Mayor
Michael Bloomberg will shut down after
today the worship services have scores
what he calls religious groups at least
57 churches and synagogues are affected
separation of church and state is one of
the basics of our country Bloomberg said
at the time the more religious you are I
think the more you should want to keep
the separation because some day the
religion the state picks is the state
religion might not be yours
so he closed down a bunch of religious
services that were taking place inside
of schools and it's it's truly that this
guy is not in any way a moderate and yet
he because the Democratic parties moved
so far to the left is now a moderate
he's now considered a moderate by the
way that policy was so bad on churches
that Bill DeBlasio reversed it in any
case
Bloomberg being a person with a lot of
money and a lot of time on his hands he
has now announced he's jumping and
according to Politico former New York
City Mayor Michael Bloomberg is
preparing to file paperwork to qualify
for the Democratic presidential primary
in Alabama ahead of a Friday deadline
the move would be a first step toward
national campaign now Bloomberg has not
made a decision to run we now need to
finish the job and ensure that Trump is
defeated but Mike is increasingly
concerned that the current field of
candidates is not well positioned to do
that longtime Bloomberg aid Howard
Wolfson said in an email if Mike runs he
would offer a new choice to Democrats
built on a unique record running
America's biggest city building a
business from scratch and taking on some
of America's toughest challenges as a
high-impact philanthropist see the
problem is that while Bloomberg is
pretty far to the left on a lot of
issues he still happens to be a
capitalist who's not completely insane
on the state of Israel and that means he
has no shot at the nomination none zero
zip zilch but he could carve into Joe
Biden just a little bit he could seem
carbonylate so Elizabeth Warren should
be pretty happy today that Bloomberg is
jumping into the race because obviously
he's not gonna draw support away from
Elizabeth Warren he's gonna draw support
away from Joe Biden if he draws any
level of support at all now honestly
when I first saw that Bloomberg was
running I thought okay maybe he's
running as an independent I mean because
if he had run as an independent I think
there's a shot that Michael Bloomberg
could win
15% of the boat is an independent
President Trump is pretty unpopular
across the country the Democrats are
gonna run a radical somebody running
down the middle could actually create a
fairly large ground swell but Bloomberg
instead is gonna run inside the
Democratic Party and he's immediately
gonna be ousted we'll talk a little bit
more about this in just one second first
let's talk about our veterans who our
veterans obviously they are heroes
they're doing braver things than I am
for sure they are doing things that are
incredible every single day and that's
why the u.s. CCA
supports veterans and they support all
Americans and they also are taking
advantage of the limited time
opportunity this month to allow you and
veterans to protect the best with 19
free chances to win $1,000 for the
military gun of your choice the military
is doing amazing work and you should
have the same level of protection that
our military members do in order so that
you can protect your rights in source
that you can protect you can use
self-defense in order to protect
yourself that you are responsibly armed
American and you should be you could own
the same gun that's carried by the US
Army Special Forces Marine Corps or
Coast Guard not fully automatic weaponry
of course because that would be illegal
in the United States but the same kind
of gun that is used effectively by the
greatest members of America text the
word wind 287 to 2 to 4 you're 19 three
chances to win and to reveal some of the
incredible guns that could be yours
don't miss your chance to win this
month's very special offer text win 287
- to - to claim your 19 entries right
now it's free
100% real completely safe text win and
that is WI n 287 - 2 - go check them out
right now the occa by the way wants to
make sure not only that responsibly
armed Americans are responsibly armed
they also make sure that you have all
the resources for education that you
require as a responsibly aren't American
they have the legal resources necessary
to defend you in case god forbid you
have to fire a shot in order to defend
your family go check them out right now
text win 287 - 2 - okay so Politico says
Bloomberg has engaged in a will he or
won't he routine for longer than a
decade about running for president but
he's declined to jump in each time
earlier this year he was exploring a bid
only to bow out after former VP Joe
Biden made clear he would run Bloomberg
said back in March I believe I would
defeat Trump in a general election but
I'm clear-eyed about the difficulty of
winning the Democratic nomination in
such a crowded field he's tired of being
the Omo strands have one former
Bloomberg advisor on Thursday mortality
is weighing heavily on him this is the
last time he can run
so basically this is a personal decision
because he's afraid that he's gonna
become irrelevant
Bloomberg won't qualify for the next
debate in Atlanta on November 20th he'll
have to spend tens of millions of bucks
in the next few weeks to make the debate
stage in December that's okay though
because his current wealth is estimated
at 52 billion dollars
he's got plenty of money to go around
asked why Bloomberg changed his mind
they'd said it's not about any one
candidate but he said he's worried about
the state of the Democratic primary
campaign the possibility we could lose
in November he wants to avoid that more
than anything else
Elizabeth Warren as I say immediately
came out and ripped into him for being a
billionaire so did Bernie Sanders's
campaign managers he being a useless
human being was lived on the taxpayers
ol for the last several decades while
passing no significant legislation in
Congress that's better than being a
billionaire who built up a business and
then ran the city of New York for a
decade more billionaires seeking more
political power surely isn't the change
America needs said Sanders his campaign
manager phii's Shakir Sanders way not
weighed in on Twitter saying the
billionaire class is scared and they
should be scared I again I do love the
fact that inside the Democratic Party
somebody who built themselves up from
pretty much nothing to be worth fifty
two billion dollars into the enemy that
person's bad clearly the people we
should have running the country are not
people who are capable of building up
wealth people who are capable of running
a business people who are capable of
running a city instead it should be
useless people who are kicked out of a
commune for not doing enough work like
Bernie Sanders and then lived off the
taxpayer dime since the time they were
thirty obviously I mean if I have to
choose between you know a successful
businessperson and a complete useless
buffoon whose only level of credibility
was achieved by running against Hillary
Clinton which by the way is the easiest
way to achieve credibility and running
against Hillary Clinton it turns out is
basically gold for everyone Bernie
Sanders Donald Trump Barack Obama like
it's fantastic in fact it but but if the
Democratic Party has to choose between
Bloomberg and Sanders they will choose
Sandberg Sanders Elizabeth Warren doing
the same routine which is rich in irony
considering the fact again Elizabeth
Warren is worth a lot of money she is
she's not a poor lady she says if you're
looking for policy plans that will make
a huge difference for working people and
which are very popular
start here and then she clicked a link
to her wealth tax because obviously this
is all just class warfare and the wealth
tax is very popular with people
of course it's popular it's always been
a popular
position that if you can legally steal
from somebody else then great right
people tend to back the idea that they
can steal money from other people so
long as they can get away with it David
Axelrod who is an aide to Barack Obama
said that really what this is about as
Bloomberg being concerned that Biden was
gonna collapse here apparently Axelrod
said there's no question that
Bloomberg's calculus was that Biden was
occupying a space the fact he's getting
in is a clear indication he's not
convinced Biden has the wherewithal to
carry that short torch so yeah I don't
think this is a positive development for
Joe Biden Bloomberg has been ripping
into Warren's wealth tax proposal he
suggested her policies toward the rich
could lead the United States on a path
to becoming Venezuela which of course is
true if you take them far enough
Bloomberg would be the second
billionaire to jump in after Tom Styer
Joe Trippi Democratic strategist said he
didn't think the form of New York City
Mayor would enter the race without a
realistic path to victory
he says they probably did some actual
polling so you know there there is the
feeling that this is at least more
serious but hardest-hit is not Elizabeth
Warren hardest hit is Joe Biden speaking
of Elizabeth Warren her radicalism is on
full display
so she was endorsed at yesterday by
black women for black women's women's I
don't even know how it women for okay
which is a group it swimming s'en
because they don't want to say men
because men is a very bad word right
really so they spelled women WOM X n
which makes it uh Turley unpronounceable
it's like it's like FUBU right the the
crazed monster the crazed scientific the
science fiction monster from from
fiction literature women thank you black
women szidon that's right pronounce it
black and then elizabeth warren got
their endorsement black trans insists
women gender non-conforming and
non-binary people are the backbone of
our democracy and i don't take this
endorsement isolate lightly i'm
committed to fighting alongside you for
the big structural change our country
needs black trans insists women gender
non-conforming and non-binary people are
the backbone of our democracy if by that
she just means like all americans are
the backbone of our democracy sure why
not like you're in america and welcome
in the backbone of our democracy if she
specifically means that like the key to
our democracy are gender non-conforming
and non-binary people
and black trans and sis women I'm gonna
need some I'm needed to show her work on
that one
I grew like if they're more significant
than say they're just as significant as
anybody else yes agree if you're saying
there are more like there's a backbone
of the democracy I'm gonna need her to
show me some math because I'm not not
seeing how that works but this is
Elizabeth Warren stick now the problem
for Elizabeth Warren again is that she
is completely out of touch with reality
she happens to be completely inauthentic
and so again Bloomberg jumping in the
race helps Biden I mean help it helps
her against Biden but Elizabeth Warren
is not doing herself any favors
demonstrating once again her
inauthenticity she she said yesterday at
an event that if she had to choose beam
going out on the town and Netflix and
chill she favors Netflix and chill I
don't think she knows what that means
here's Elizabeth Lauren saying a thing
okay Netflix and chill or Broadway and
dinner Oh
Netflix and chill okay pretty sure she
doesn't know what that means
it doesn't mean you you only watch
Netflix just did that over the last
several years that term has more fairly
significantly she's but she's with the
people she was ok bloomer it's not her
only area of craze so the entire
Democratic Party yesterday they were
doing the climate change Dec and that
means it's time to propose ridiculous
things so Bernie Sanders came out and
proposed that his green New Deal was
going to require an expenditure of 17
trillion dollars because money just
comes directly from the ass of a unicorn
so you can just spend that money on
fighting the Sun or you can spend that
money on ignoring the fact that China
and India are not lowering their
emissions anytime soon and that the
United States is the leading decrease or
in emissions in the world and has been
for the last several years you can you
can spend all that money to no effect
but Bernie Sanders admitted it's really
not a been on Twitter he said this is
not about actually lowering climate
change is about restructuring the
economy Elizabeth Warren had some words
on climate changes well we'll get to all
that in just one second first here is a
straight fact going to the post office
it's a waste of time now the post office
is great they offered fantastic services
but last time I went to the post office
I got a ticket on the curb I had to wait
in line why would you do all that when
you can just get all the great services
of the post office directly from your
home computer
stamps.com brings all the services of
the US Postal Service directly to your
computer whether you're a small office
sending invoices and online seller
shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
or drop it in a mailbox it is indeed
that simple with stamps comm you get
five cents off every first class stamp
up to 40% off Priority Mail
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already use stamps comm so if
you haven't tried it yet there's really
nothing for you to wait for there's a
reason I use stamps comm personally
there's a reason that stamps comm is
used by our office managers here at the
Daily wire don't spend a minute of your
holiday season at the post office this
year send everything from home sign up
for stamps comm instead no risk and with
my promo code Shapiro you get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and the digital scale
no long term commitments or contracts
using our code you'll be saving money
and supporting the show just go to
stamps comm click on the Mike at the top
of the homepage type in Shapiro that is
stamps comm enter code Shapiro stamps
calm and don't go to the post office
ever again okay so when Elizabeth Warren
isn't pretending to be a woman of the
people who likes to Netflix and chill
she is saying she's making dire
predictions about the future of Earth
because the world is warming here's
Elizabeth Warren suggesting that there
will be fights over land and water
unlike the rest of human history when
there has never been a fight over land
in water as the shorelines impinge on
their traditional homelands they will
become climate refugees and it's true
all around the world
the consequence of that is not simply
that people will need aid and help but
it's also that it will produce more
conflict there will be fights over water
there will be fights over land that can
be farmed for food ok so again all these
dire sort of predictions they're not
really borne out by sort of the best
available projections you're all you
hear this all the time that it's going
to cause mass migration well over the
course of the next hundred years there
will be population movement this has
also been true throughout human history
and when she makes these predictions
about the rise in terrorism and William
Nordhaus writes about this in his book
climate cuz you know these are these are
things that are largely unpredictable
the idea that she can forecast a hundred
years into the future with her
magic wand her man she's got her magic
mirror on the wall and says show me
climate refugees and people keep saying
its climate refugees in Syria no it's
pretty much not about climate refugees
in Syria it's pretty much about the fact
that the Syrian regime has been
slaughtering wholesale its enemies
trying to trying to blame war on climate
is it's hard to do that it really is and
you want to know one way that you're
actually going to be able to alleviate a
lot of the a lot of the environmental
degradation with regards to loss of
water and all of this that would be
increased GDP but there are a lot of
places on earth that don't have
tremendous natural resources and thanks
to increased GDP they are able to take
care of themselves unfortunately the
proposals that Warren and her crew
endorsed are exactly the same sort of
proposals that undercut the ability of
developing countries to actually
develops they're not reliant as much on
the exact sources that are going to be
undermined by the climate change that
she fears it's not just Elizabeth Warren
doing this routine and Cory Booker is
saying crazy things too so Cory Booker
who again is a completed relevancy in
this particular race he came out
yesterday he said that he was gonna make
foreign aid from the United States
contingent on adopting American climate
change policies which is bizarre and
crazy because if you're making
contingent foreign aid to Africa if they
if the contingency is that they have to
adopt our climate emissions policy
literally they're trying to keep their
people from having to use dung as fuel
over there I can't think of anything
more cruel than saying our foreign aid
to you is now dependent on you picking
up developed world standards of climate
emissions of carbon emissions well
you're just trying to keep your people
from living past dying before the age of
here's cory booker saying something dumb
america is the indispensable leader on
the planet to deal with this issue
without us we're not going to get there
and so this is not just rejoining the
Paris climate Accords which I will do
right away it's actually using every
lever of foreign policy we have four
more foreign aid to countries making a
continue
on climate action it means using our
diplomacy our alliances our trade deal
center - there must be labor and climate
okay well good luck with this really the
key to actually developing beyond
carbon-based fuels is going to be
prosperity not poverty and linking
linking trade to people making
conditional conditional policy about
climate emissions is about the worst way
of reducing climate emissions that you
could possibly think of then you just
got Bernie Sanders who's just completely
crazy he says don't worry we'll create
20 million new jobs fighting global
warming now Sanders believes in the
labor theory of value like the Marxist
labor theory of value so he thinks that
if we just hire 20 million people to dig
ditches that we have created 20 million
new jobs maybe he's an actual believer
that if you create if you create a job a
person sitting on the side of the road
making a pie out of mud that you've now
created a job that's how you create jobs
who's Bernie Sanders saying dumb things
I'm not here to suggest the mic plan is
gonna solve every problem but my plan
understands the severity of the crisis
and acts boldly and in the process when
we make a fundamental transition away
from fossil fuel to energy efficiency
and sustainable energy we create 20
million new jobs there will be some job
loss but we create 20 million new jobs
yeah there will be some job loss like in
every major industry in the United
States and by the way you're not gonna
create twenty minutes I love that again
the Democratic Party is saying that
Bernie Sanders knows how to create jobs
but Michael Bloomberg does not then
Elizabeth Warren knows how to create
jobs but Bill Gates does not the full
scale insanity of a party that suggests
that people who are professors and
lifelong legislators have never achieved
anything that those are the people we
should rely upon to run the United
States economy like this is what Trump
should be running against obviously this
is what the campaign should be about and
Democrats know that that's what the
campaign should be about which is why
obviously they're focusing in on
impeachment that's why they're spending
every waking moment thinking how do we
sink president Trump's approval ratings
through all of this impeachment stuff
now Trump is not handling himself great
on the impeachment stuff as you would
fully predict the reason being that
President Trump is sort of offended that
the stuff is even happening in the first
place and of course he's offended by the
fact that the media are willing to run
with literally any story there's an
incredibly na
credible non-credible book by the author
of the book is called a warning by an
anonymous author supposedly a top
staffer in the Trump White House and
it's not credible because literally the
very first thing that was revealed about
the book is that the book suggested that
Mike Pence was ready to invoke the 25th
amendment against Trump it was
completely non credible is that stopping
the media from running front page
stories about the book of course not
instead you've got the Washington Post
running pieces by Philip Rucker about
how the presidency is on the brink
the piece says senior Trump
administration officials considered
resigning on mass last year in a
midnight self massacre to sound a public
alarm about president Trump's conduct
but rejected the idea because they
believe it would further destabilize an
already teetering government according
to a new book by an unnamed author and
these are these are just completely wild
speculative comments with no basis in
actual evidence and it's being run on by
the media I mean the media are fully
invested in building up the narrative
that things are crazy over at the White
House that it's impeachment aid Oh again
because you look at that Democratic
field when it's that it when it's so
weak that Michael Bloomberg is like you
know what I've been waiting for 20 years
to jump in now is the time and that's
how you know the Democrats have a
problem in a second we're going to get
see the latest in impeachment gauge 2019
but first let's talk about crypto
currency so you hear crypto currency and
a lot of people like I don't know
anything about that it sounds kind of
shady all crypto currency is it's
basically digital gold right all it is
is you are investing in a currency that
is protected by blockchain so it can't
be inflated or manipulated by central
governments that's all cryptocurrency is
and so when you are looking to invest in
something that is not subject to the
whims of centralized governments many
people many very smart people they said
George Gildan for example our big fans
of cryptocurrency specifically because
they're not in favor of the government
being able to manipulate how much your
money is actually worth like last week
China devalued its currency markets
tanked Bitcoin prices rose that is not a
shock again every time governments mess
with their currency Bitcoin prices right
crypto markets rise
well eToro is smart crypto trading made
easy eToro social trading platform has
over 11 million traders and facilitates
over 1 million 1 trillion dollars in
trading volume prettier globally you can
access the world's best crypto
currencies they got 15 different coins
available low and transparent fees and I
love this you can try before we get
trade they give you a virtual portfolio
100,000 dollar budgets he can actually
see how the market works before you
spend any of your own money never miss a
trading trend with charts and pricing
alerts as well sign up today at eToro
comm slash appear o ET o ro comm slash
appear o try out that virtual portfolio
it's pretty cool eToro comm slash
apparel go check them out right now okay
so the Democrats are apparently now
moving their deadline to Christmas so
originally they said they were gonna try
and move this thing by the end of
October
then they said they're gonna move this
thing by the end of Thanksgiving now
they say they're gonna move this thing
by Christmas I have my doubts I think
they're probably gonna carry this thing
over into next year again because as
they see that their field is weak it
behooves them to carry the impeachment
thing forward into 2020 so the original
idea was we get this thing over quick
and dirty
we know we don't necessarily have enough
and therefore we are going to just do it
get our base on board and then we move
on to the election but as they see that
their own field is filled with problems
as they see that their own field is is
filled with radicals who do not have a
wonderful chance at winning in the
middle of the country their best play is
to push impeachment through into next
year so make him wrong maybe this thing
ends by Christmas I have serious doubts
I think it is much more likely that this
thing pushes forward all the way into
the Democratic primaries so the
Democrats can keep going into debates
and instead of debating each other they
can rip on Trump being super corrupt
according to CNN House Democrats are
signaling they are now on a fast track
in their impeachment proceedings
avoiding court battles that could delay
their inquiry limiting the number of
witnesses at public hearings all signs
that President Trump could be impeached
as soon as next month House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi has not shared her thinking
on the final timeline with her
colleagues Democratic sources say the
timing is still fluid and could continue
to evolve but in a series of moves this
week Democrats have shown they are
rapidly moving to complete the
proceedings by Christmas something that
could result in Trump being just the
third president to be impeached in
history the schedule became apparent
according to CNN in recent days after
House Intelligence chairman Adam Schiff
a California Democrat announced that
public hearings would begin next week
and also suggested Thursday that there's
a limit to the witnesses that they would
call for the public hearings now again I
don't think that that is absolutely
correct I think that if the Democrats
feel like they are actually making
political hey if they're watching the
polls and the polls start to rise in
terms of support for impeachment they're
going to lay this thing they're gonna
continue to drag it out because why rush
it makes more
little cents they actually have this
thing take a while the more TV time you
get worse it hurts Trump would be the
theory plus Democrats also withdrew
subpoena of a former White House
official to ensure their proceedings
were not delayed by a court battle so
they decided not to subpoena john bolton
because john bolton said we're gonna
have to get a court order and they're
like no no no we're not gonna do that
yeah everybody's logic has sort of been
shifting on this the democrats
originally wanted to fast-track it then
they want a slow track it now supposedly
they want a fast track it again the next
phases of house impeachment proceedings
could conclude before 2020 apparently
Schiff has announced three witnesses
will testify it next week publicly
Democratic lawmakers expect at least one
more week of public hearings before his
panel likely to follow on the week of
November 18th now here's the thing some
of the testimony favors from a lot of
the testimony does not favor from the
theory that is now being trotted out by
some in sort of Trump's camp and in the
Republican Senate is that okay fine so
there were people who wanted to quid pro
quo there were people who wanted to
pressure Ukraine using military aid to
go after Joe Biden but it wasn't really
Trump it was really all these lackeys it
was like Rudy Giuliani it was Gordon
someone this is not gonna play I'm sorry
this narrative is not going to play it's
not gonna play because it's obviously
not true it isn't if you think that Rudy
Giuliani was freelancing with Sunderland
without Trump's approval he is Trump's
personal attorney if you think that
Trump was not involved in talking with
Rudy about what was going on in Ukraine
and about those investigations that is
not credible and yet today you had
President Trump like he's his own worst
defense lawyer it's truly incredible
here as president from today suggesting
Gordon Sunland I barely even know Gordon
said the reason Gordon Sunland is the EU
ambassadors cuz he gave million bucks to
Trump in the 2016 election cycle here is
Trump claiming that he doesn't know who
Gordon Sunland is let me just say I
hardly know the gentleman but this is
the man who said there was no quid pro
quo and he still says that and he said
that I said that and he hasn't change a
testimony so this is a man that said as
far as the president is concerned there
was no quid pro quo everybody that
specified even the ones that are Trump
haters they've all been fine they don't
have anything okay well he the last
defense right which is that they're all
saying if there is a quid pro quo
they're saying that based on three
party testimony or based on their own
perception of the issues that's true but
the I don't know board in some one thing
and the attempt to say well maybe this
is all cooked up by you know Kurt Volker
and Sunland and Giuliani independent of
Trump that's not going to work it's not
going to work the best defense as always
is the defense that was laid out by me
and then it's been picked up by some in
the Senate including senator Cruz the
best defense here is that President
Trump overall was interested in
Ukrainian corruption in the 2016
election and that in his mind he'd been
given a bunch of information by Rudy
Giuliani some of it bad he wrapped it
all up in a ball and he said I want all
of this cleared up before the aid goes
to Ukraine right that was always the
best defense it remains the best defense
and by the way it is back to a certain
extent by testimony of some of the
witnesses Democrats are calling so one
of the people who was who was called and
whose whose testimony has now been
publicly revealed is deputy assistant
secretary George Kent who oversaw
Ukraine policy at the State Department
so according to the media they're
ignoring the actual interesting part of
his testimony he told lawmakers that
Trump demanded that the country's new
president Vladimir zalenski announce
investigations into the 2016 election
Trump's former rival Hillary Clinton and
former VP Joe Biden in exchange for an
oval office meeting he said that Trump
wanted nothing less and President
Solinsky to go to a microphone and say
investigations Biden and Clinton that's
what he said in his testimony but he
also acknowledged that he'd not heard
that directly from Trump he said that
that was not something that he and from
ever personally discussed so that was
his perception so his perception is as
good as your perception on all of this
he doesn't have inside information that
that is exactly what Trump wanted he's
seeing the same material that you have
now seen publicly but there's another
problem which is that buried deep down
in this New York Times article about all
of this is Ken's acknowledging that
there were significant concerns inside
the State Department about wait for it
Joe Biden circa 2015 I'm reading
directly to you from the testimony of
George Kent now
hey the questioner says the vice
president's involvement with Ukraine is
pretty significant at that point of time
in time and it remained until he you
know through 2016 correct and Kent says
yes and then the questioner says the
question was you know were there any
discussions have perceived conflict of
interest on the part of either hunter
Biden or the vice president answer when
I was the first time I was in Ukraine as
acting deputy chief of mission in the
period mid January to mid February 2015
subsequent to me going into the deputy
prosecutor general on February 3rd
demanding who took the bribe and how
much of it was to shut the case against
it slow Chesky I became aware that
Hunter Biden was on the board I didn't
know that at the time and when I was on
a call with somebody on the VP staff I
can't recall who it was just briefing on
what was happening in Ukraine
I raised my concerns I had heard that
hunter Biden was on the board of a
company owned by somebody that the US
government had spent money trying to get
tens of millions of dollars back and
that it could create the perception of a
conflict of interest question what did
the person on the other end of the line
tell you the message I recall hearing
back was that the vice president's son
Beau was dying of cancer and that there
was no further bandwidth to deal with
family related issues at that time he
says that was the end of that
conversation okay that's a pretty
suspicious answer is it not I mean does
that mean that it's really all that bad
for Trump to raise the question of
hunter Biden George ken's himself is
saying it's pretty suspicious that
hunter Biden is on that board I raised
it with the Obama administration they
said oh we didn't have the bandwidth
because beau is dying
I'm not aware that the entire federal
government runs the behest of the vice
presidents of the United States it seems
like the Vice President should at least
take the question as to what that's not
a family related issue that's a
corruption related issue so it's pretty
amazing it's pretty amazing right Jim
Jordan ask your Newbery's Moe was a
trouble to corrupt company right and Ken
said it had a reputation for not being
the cleanest member of the business
community so that all of this you know
raises some serious questions and that
means that Trump's best defense as
always that there is this bag of
corruption in Ukraine it includes hunter
and Joe Biden and that's what he was
talking about and it also includes his
wrongfully informed perceptions of
CrowdStrike etc there's another story
today the Tucker Carlson broke on his
show last night in which he is claiming
that Murray ivanovitch who was appointed
to be US ambassador to Ukraine
allegedly made false statements under
oath during her October 11th closed-door
testimony in House Democrats impeachment
inquiry we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about the
quality of your employees so the fact is
that my employees here at the Daily wire
they're just great across the board they
really are great across the board but
occasionally occasionally they forget to
do the kinds of things that date that
they should do occasionally they forget
to reverse the teleprompter to make sure
that the clocks work let's say that
there's a guy named Nick and let's say
that he just forgot to check whether the
clocks worked before the
one thing let's call it yesterday and it
made it much more difficult to do the
show well if at that point I was
thinking you know I really need someone
better than Nick the place I would check
out is zip recruiter com why because
zipper crew makes sure that you get the
best candidates fast you need the best
candidates fast with the results like
zip recruiter provides it's no wonder
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter get a quality kanzen it
within the very first day don't worry
nick is fine he's not gonna be fired or
anything I mean at least not yet we
haven't even posted his job description
on zip recruiter yet see why zip
recruiter is effective for businesses of
all sizes try zip recruiter for free at
our web address zip recruit comm slash
daily wire at soup recruiters comm slash
Dai ly Wira zip recruiter comm slash
daily y our zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire ok more on
impeachment gate and we'll get to
roger's don't also I want to do some
mail bagging we haven't done mail bag on
the on the show on the podcast for a
while but first if you're not already a
subscriber you're really missing out
head on over to daily wire.com slash
subscribe for as little as ten bucks a
month you get our articles ad free
access to all of our live broadcast our
full library select bonus contents and
our exclusive daily wiretaps so
exclusive so beautiful and it's like
being able to get into the special VIP
room at the club if you choose the new
all-access plan you'll get that that
plus the legendary leftist yours tumbler
ooh and our brand-new ask me anything
style discussion feature that allows you
to engage our host right or a special
guest on a weekly basis I believe I'm
doing one of those today actually
so stop depriving yourself come join the
fun also it is indeed that glorious time
of the week when I give a shout out to a
daily wire subscriber since I was in
Israel we couldn't do this but now we
can today it's a Twitter er named Sam
who understands the importance of
hydration and brain stimulation while
working through the wee hours in the
picture Sam has his elite beverage
vessel and copy of my book the right
side of history sitting in front of a
bright yellow US Coast Guard helicopter
which is awesome sauce the caption reads
nothing like a good book and some warm
salty tears to help pass the time on the
night shift
hashtag left his tears tumblr kudos to
you Sam we're glad we could help thanks
for the picture thanks for your service
as always again go check us out over
daily we're DICOM got all sorts of
goodies for you
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
you
speaking of further developments in the
in the impeachment gait saga apparently
according to Ryan's veteran reporting
for daily we're calm Murray ivanovitch
who was appointed to be the US
ambassador to Ukraine by former
President Obama allegedly made false
statements under oath during her October
11th closed-door testimony in House
Democrats his impeachment inquiry
according to Fox News is Tucker Carlson
before the contents of the whistleblower
complaint were known publicly a
democratic congressional staffer
contacted the former American ambassador
to Ukraine to discuss what the staffer
described as a quite delicate and
time-sensitive question this show has
obtained exclusively an email for that
Democratic staffer for the House Foreign
Affairs Committee sent by private email
to the former American ambassador Murray
Ivanovich Carlson continued Ivanovitch
you know is a key player in the
Democrats impeachment probe that was
recalled from her post in Ukraine by
President Trump in May 2019 following
allegations of serious partisanship and
political bias the email that Carlson
obtained States quote I'm reading to see
if you would have time to meet up for a
chat in particular I'm hoping to discuss
some Ukraine related oversight questions
we are exploring I'd appreciate the
change to ground truth a few pieces of
information with you some of which are
quite delicate and time-sensitive in us
we want to make sure we get them right
that email was sent out on August 14th
said Carlson two days after the
whistleblower complaint was filed a
month before the complaint became public
the whistleblower however went to Adam
Schiff steam before filing the
complaints the question Carlson says is
did shifts office tell other Democrats
on Capitol Hill what was in the
complaint in other words how long did
this effort play out in secret before
the rest of the country learned of it
Carlson also noted that representative
Lee Zeldin of New York asked Ivanovich
about email during her testimony and she
allegedly stated she never responded to
that email Carlson says in fact it turns
out she did respond she said she looked
forward to chatting with the Democratic
staffer as congressman Zeldin pointed
out the ambassador's original answer
which was dishonest was given under oath
Zeldin confirmed that Carlson segments
whether he wrote it appears ambassador
Jovanovic did not accurately answer this
question I asked her during her
impeachment inquiry deposition under
oath so that could be a problem Fox
News's Greg ray later reported that
Jovanovic replied to the staff are
identified by Fox News is Laura Kerry
saying she would love to reconnect and
look forward to chatting with you Selden
told Fox News I would highly suspect
this democratic staffers work was
connected in some way to the
whistleblowers effort which has evolved
into this impeachment charade we do know
that
whistle blower was in contact with shift
steam before the whistle blower had even
hired an attorney or filed the
whistleblower complaint even though
Schiff had lied to the public originally
claiming there was no contact Zeldin
says I specifically asked you Voinovich
whether the Democratic staffer was
responded to by Jovanovic or the State
Department it is greatly concerning that
Jovanovic didn't answer my questions as
honestly she should have especially well
under oath so people on the right are
pointing out well if he voinovich was
not telling the truth under oath should
that be a legal problem for her
considering that we are now in the
process of a major trial of Roger stone
specifically for lying to investigators
it is again several things and I always
like to say it can be going on at once
then going on number one there can be
troubling questions to be asked about
the Trump Ukraine withholding of
military aid what's done for personal
benefit or political benefit was it done
instead because Trump received
corruption in Ukraine all right those
are questions that are going to be asked
and answered also was this whole thing
organized behind the scenes by Adam
Schiff his way to get Trump they can
both be true but certainly if this looks
like a partisan effort by Democrats to
quote-unquote get Trump organized with
the help of Democratic partisans in the
so-called deep State that's really gonna
undercut the credibility of the inquiry
ultimately which is why you're seeing
Adams chef now say that he doesn't want
the whistleblower interviewed by the way
is another story today about the
whistleblower suggesting that the
whistleblower apparently was a Biden
guest at a State Department banquet in
October of 2016 to honor the front Prime
Minister of Italy so all of this it can
all be a mess and it appears to all be a
mess okay you know we haven't done
mailbag in a while so let's do some
mailbag here on the bench of you
Rochelle
Ariel says Haven I've had a question on
my mind for some time now would like
your insight considering all the people
who have left the Democratic Party due
to movements like Jax it is flex it and
walk away do you think Trump is headed
for a landslide also how do we believe
the pools after the 2016 the polls I
assume after the 2016 Fiasco thanks for
your hard work and all you do okay so I
don't know that Trump is headed for a
landslide I think that the country is
too closely divided for anybody to win a
landslide anymore I just don't think the
dad is a thing that is likely to happen
unless the economy tanks in which it
would be a landslide the other way I
will say that some of the new polls
particularly the swing states are
showing surprising Trump resiliency
particularly among minorities
is pulling better among minorities in
terms of approval rating than he did
back in 2016 if he starts to carve away
some of those numbers from the
Democratic base they've got a real
problem on their hands yeah listen I
think the minority groups in the United
States have been ill served by the
Democratic Party I think the Democratic
Party has counted on their support and
done nothing for them I think that
they've basically misdirected away from
the fact that the Democratic Party has
not served members of the black
community the Jewish community the the
Hispanic community I think that they've
they've lied about that by basically
suggesting that Republicans are anti
black anti-hispanic anti-jewish and all
the rest of this nonsense but the fact
is that the Republican Party can always
do a better job of outreach it'll be
interest Lee I'll be fascinated to see
in 2020 whether Trump actually carves it
into some of those numbers because he
did not under perform Trump did not on
his perform among Hispanics in 2016
he performed basically the same as MIT
Romney did and among black voters there
was some suggestion that he may have
outperformed Romney among black voters
in that those numbers may be growing so
that'll be fascinating to watch Alex
says one of my closest friends from high
school whom I've lost contact with since
graduation several years ago has
transitioned to what I assume is the
female gender though he is using they're
prone and he's using pronouns they
they're I'll be meeting with him on
Monday for the first time since his
transition he was one of my closest
friends I know him well and know that he
has struggled with depression for many
years he has never showed any signs of
femininity or any desire to become
female I'd like to help him but don't
know how any suggestions would be
welcomed I love your show thanks for all
you do well I mean frankly look in
personal relationships you always treat
people with sensitivity this is
completely separate from the generalized
question as to whether we should
acknowledge that men can become women
and women can become men so I've said
before on this show and in public that
and I've done this before
that if you are in a personal one-on-one
conversation with somebody who is
transgender
then you treat them normally meaning
like yong-chol out of your way to say
things that are gonna make them feel bad
obviously with that said if you are on
such an intimate basis with this person
if you're on such a a first person basis
with this person that you can say to
them listen I only want what's best for
you and I'm afraid that you're making
decisions about yourself and your body
that are gonna be damaging to you long
term I know you well enough to know that
this is a mistake what you're doing
then there's nothing wrong with saying
that really I mean I'm bewildered by the
idea that you always have
like that you can't intervene with
anybody regardless of their personal
condition if somebody in your family
were depressed and they were considering
doing something to add to themselves you
would intervene and you would say like I
think this is a mistake if you're on
that level with somebody now for not on
that level then going out of your way to
offend the person I think is dumb but
that's only something that you can tell
between you and the other person how
close your relationship is now none of
that has any impact on the generalized
political debate as to whether the war
should pretend that men who say they are
women are actually women the answer
there is no or whether the law should
compel people to use preferred pronouns
the answer is no is violative of the
First Amendment and Violet of basic
biology but on a sensitivity level there
are lots of things you do that are
sensitive to other people they don't
want to prove done on a societal level
you always treat people with sensitivity
and decency on a personal level even if
you believe the generalized policy is
best off setting up an incentive
structure that does not incentivize bad
behavior
umeri says I really enjoyed your talk at
Stanford this week appreciate it I
recently had a conversation with a
friend about whether there is systemic
racism in the United States and she
brought up some studies that suggest
black patients are taken less seriously
by doctors and as a result have worse
health outcomes than non black patients
for the same diseases and conditions do
you have any insight or alternative
explanation for these statistics thanks
for everything you do so I have I have
taken a look at a lot of these studies
and I don't find the studies to be
entirely credible and the reason I don't
find the studies to be entirely credible
and you can cite particular studies we
can go through them actually there there
are specific studies that suggest that
for example when black patients are our
report a certain level of pain they get
opioids less frequently than white
patients do now is that a result of
people being racist against black people
or is that a result of the of there
being a generalized a generalized
concern about the white patients being
more whiny you know in terms of an in
terms of Yelp for example like these
things actually do play into how doctors
treat patients unfortunately I mean in
in blind study it is also true that when
you that that attempting to attribute
all of this to race as opposed to
behavioral differences in patients
patients behave differently all the time
I mean they really do and trying to
attribute that to a racial divide
specifically tends not to work now I'd
want to actually go through the specific
studies that are being cited and because
there have been a bunch of them but they
always
to be more correlative than causative
it's not like a black person comes in to
there was one study for example that
showed that doctors who are less good
tended to believe in things about black
patients that were not true
like black patients have thicker skin or
something and the answer to that is not
that the entire medical profession is
racist is that doctors who suck at
things also tend not to know things they
tend to be bad doctors and doctors who
are bad or Bad's that's a study that
shows that bad doctors are bad doctors
not that doctors are generally racist
and therefore the doctors are treating
black patients worse so I'm very
suspicious of studies that suggest that
doctors overall are somehow imbued with
the sense of racism in medical school
like again I don't see the evidence for
that it's it's it's sort of a weird
supposition and the studies that I've
seen again tend it be more correlative
than closet.if they'll take a bad doctor
who doesn't know things and then they'll
be like oh the bad doctor doesn't know
things that means that the bad doctor is
a racist and that racism is widespread
and that's a bit of a stretch Elijah
says Haven loved the show well I'm a
libertarian personally I've got a few
Bernie bro friends are all enchanted by
the political work of no I'm Chomsky
claiming that America's political
systems are controlled by corporate
interests that the wealthy control all
of society we need economic democracy
etc what are some good arguments that
rebuke these contentions well I mean how
about the fact that a huge number of
people who go into politics including
Bernie Sanders are wildly successful by
ripping on rich people Elizabeth Warren
is probably gonna win the Democratic
nomination by ripping on rich people the
the idea that corporations control the
United States government while the
corporate tax rate is was not even
competitive with most of the business
world abroad for decades is somewhat
telling also it is true that there are
lots of Union interests who are quote
unquote not corporations have an
enormous amounts of power it doesn't it
doesn't line up with reality in other
words if the idea is that all of
politics is Korea is is compelled by
corporate interests is the idea that
both the Democratic Party and the
Republican Party are controlled by the
corporations which corporations are we
talking about are we talk about
left-wing corporations or right-wing
corporations and by the way if the
solution to that to have a cadre of it
so I guess the quadrate of supremely
powerful disproportionately powerful
people are controlling the United States
government so your solution to that is
to create a cadre of completely on and
durable powerful people not answerable
to outside American voting or economic
investment in politics but stand at the
top of the government and just
distribute everything so your answer to
a powerful cadre of people controlling
the United States government is a more a
more powerful cadre of people who have
never created a job controlling the
power of government make sense in crazy
towns pennant says we recently had a
transgender male-to-female join our
company I've been organizing my thoughts
on transgender topics well I don't agree
with the transgender agenda I'm still a
bit confused about why civil rights laws
might not apply to the transgender
community for example I recently read
that religiously affiliated adoption
agencies can opt not to provide services
to anyone who is LGBT due to freedom of
religion I believe you discussed this
several times before but would you be
able to provide insight into the
transgender versus civil rights debate
well again civil rights is about race
specifically it's about immutable
characteristics and there's no just
there's no discrimination on the basis
of immutable characteristics quote
unquote discrimination against
transgender behavior is discrimination
against behavior meaning that the entire
argument of the transgender movement is
that your inward your inward
self-identification is what is being
discriminated against when you change
your outward behavior and that is a
weird statement because again the vast
majority of human behavior is connected
to some sort of inner feeling and we
discriminate on the basis of behavior
all the time there's a vast difference
between sayings who's somebody you can't
work here because you are black and an
unchangeable feature about yourself and
here's Bob and then he came into work
today dressed as Sally or here is Sally
who is a was a woman and she came into
work today
dressed as Bob but she's now having
hormone treatments and this is a Hooters
right like and she wants to work here
like and wants to be called he and his
Bob now like the problem again is that
when it comes to human behavior well the
only thing that we can treat based upon
is behavior that is outwardly visible to
people behavior that is outwardly
visible to people so there's a
difference between behaviorally driven
discrimination which is stuff that we do
every day and identity driven
discrimination what the left has done is
they've conflated inner feeling with
identity which is which is a pretty
hefty trick and pretty pretty solid
trick actually alrighty so we're gonna
do a quick thing I like a quick thing I
hate and then
well at the end of the week guys Wow
okay time for a quick thing I like so
Chris Stapleton is is a fun country
singer and he has a there's a great new
video that he that he has put out I just
enjoyed this I guess in my business
partner sent this to me and honestly I
just got a kick out of it I thought you
get a kick out of it too the entire
video is wild and crazy it basically is
a LEGO version of Chris Stapleton
concert apparently features the voice of
Chris Pratt it's a lot of fun check it
out
[Music]
it's pretty wild and crazy' go check it
out it's kind of a fun music video it's
appropriate for the kiddies and it's
kind of a kick okay time for a quick
thing that I hate okay so a couple of
quick things that I hate actually did so
according to the Christian Post parents
who filed a human rights complaint
against a school where their
six-year-old daughter was being taught
there is no such thing as boys and girls
have now filed a lawsuit against the
school board principal and the teacher
this is in Canada the teacher who taught
a first-grade class at Devon sure
community public school in Ontario
Canada last year presented a YouTube
video on gender presented a YouTube
video on gender called he/she and they
gender queer kids stuff too which was
part of the lesson plan that day pamela
Buffone the mother of six year old girl
told the post-millennial earlier this
year the phone and her husband
subsequently filed a complaint with the
Ontario Human Rights Tribunal against
the school system after their daughter
started worrying she might not be female
after watching the video last week the
justice center for constitutional
freedoms a legal advocacy organization
specializing in Canadian constitutional
law that is representing the buffoon the
buffoons and their daughter found an
amended application noting the child's
rights to security of the person in
equality or being infringed mephone said
she was very passionate about kinds of
social justice topics most of which our
daughter really enjoyed learning about
the teacher of the first grade class had
drawn a gender spectrum on the
whiteboard and asked the children where
they placed on the spectrum the phone's
daughter picked up the first the
farthest end of the spectrum designated
girl their human rights complaint claims
the teacher instructed the class that
girls are not real and boys are not real
which greatly distressed their daughter
of course it did because that's asinine
it's ridiculous in a biological and anti
scientific and the fact that this stuff
is being taught in schools now if you
think that doesn't have an impact on
kids it's because you're an idiot it's
amazing people on the left will suggest
that everything has an impact on kids
you bring your kid to a church of July
4th parade everything violence on TV it
all has an impact on your kids but then
they say we're also going to teach your
five-year-old that he can be a she and
she can be a he won't have any impact on
her kids at all yeah if you're crazy if
you're a crazy person speaking of crazy
people according to the UK Daily Mirror
a cafe has now replaced the term
gingerbread men with gender-neutral
gingerbread person which is a bit of a
mouthful just like a gingerbread man
according to the Daily Mirror when a
customer at the tannery in Auckland
question why human-shaped snacks were
called gingerbread men and not
gingerbread people owner Andre Santino
was inspired to make a change the label
on the jar has now been changed for each
gingerbread gender-neutral person which
is kind of hilarious he says it was
completely tongue-in-cheek from the
start but it's become a really good
conversation piece in the cafe he says
it used to be the ninety percent of the
time we sold the gingerbread man it was
two kids there's a lot more people
buying them now which is quite funny
apparently they posted a picture of the
jar with the caption a little something
for everyone with a winking face this is
it unbelievable unbelievable bread man
that you have to have the jar changed at
the local bakery you got problems bigger
than the gingerbread man okay we'll be
here later today with two additional
hours of content so I will see you there
then this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo white house key
edited by Adam Tsai events audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Jessica alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19 on the Matt Walsh show we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation
you